so if only seeking to prove the the
right's point about trump
right the left has decided that
basically everything must be canceled
everything is racist and here's the
thing
it's like the incredibles right if
everybody is special nobody is special
if everybody is canceled nobody is
cancelled
if you don't actually go after people
who you think deserve to be canceled
on the basis of very specific behavior
you just go after everyone you start to
get ignored you're the boy who cried
cancel
and this is what the left has become
they've become the person of unspecified
gender identity
who calls cancel that's what they are
and so we don't pay attention to you
anymore
this is a problem it's a problem for the
right it's a problem for the left
because the truth is there are certain
things that
we all find kind of gross we don't want
people saying
and there are social strictures to those
things but as a general rule the left
wants everybody they don't like canceled
and not just people they don't like for
like a great reason
not like neo-nazis they'll just label
everybody a white supremacist or a
neo-nazi
and this of course is what has driven so
many republicans to support for
people like president trump because he
is the loudest and he is the most out
there
and here's the person who's taken the
most hits and so people on the right now
associate takes the most hits
with the person who tells the truth the
most because those two things tend to be
pretty highly correlated where the left
is concerned
if you see the people the left likes to
attack the most very often it's the
people who are saying the most things
now the problem is sometimes
it's not right sometimes the left is
attacking margaery taylor
great example sometimes the left is
attacking mars retailer green for jewish
space lasers
it seems like a good pretty good reason
to go after somebody they believe that
jewish space lasers started a california
wildfire or they are
touting the q anon theory but the exact
same level of outrage met marjorie
taylor green
saying that there are two genders which
is true as her saying that there are
jewish space lasers which is crazy
so at a certain point the righteous says
we don't trust anything you people have
to say we don't trust
anything you people have to say it's why
there is so much skepticism
of the institutional media it's why
there's so much skepticism of the left
when they make claims people are not
evaluating claim by claim
whether the left is telling the truth
instead they're just ignoring the left
wholesale
and the left just keeps on doing it i
mean it's truly incredible
so for example alyssa milano is now
pushing a weird theory okay so cpac's
stage
was built in a certain way okay and
usually
it is kind of the hotel planner who
decides how the stage is going to be set
up particularly in a place like the
hyatt
alyssa milano put out a graphic
of sort of an aerial view of the stage
and she said this is a nazi symbol
she said this is the stage at cpac
they're not even trying to hide it
anymore
hyatt this is what's happening in your
building ted cruz you stood
on this stage and she says that that
stage was built in order to resemble a
nazi symbol okay you're a crazy person
i'm sorry you're totally wild you're
wild and crazy this is no less crazy
than the q and on crap
if you think that people at cpac that
matt schlapp was like you know what we
need a stage
let's make it in the shape of a giant
swastika hmm nobody will catch on
to whom are you signaling alyssa milano
you caught onto the code alyssa but
these people like alyssa milano who
dressed up in like a handmaid's tale
outfit to go to justice kavanaugh
hearings
like that person is considered a serious
human on the left
people are considered serious for
calling on the hyatt to be boycotted
because they hosted cpac
by the way good for hyatt hyatt came out
they're like you know what we host all
sorts of conferences go off yourself
this by the way should be the response
of every single corporation in america
when the wokes come for them according
to fox 26 houston
hyatt hotels defended its decision to
host the 2021 conservative political
action conference
at a time when the political climate has
become increasingly volatile
citing its belief that individuals and
organizations should be able to
peacefully gather and express their own
views
the three-day event is being held at the
hyatt regency orlando in florida
featuring a slew of prominent republican
speakers from lawmakers and former
administrations
former administration officials to
president trump
the spokesperson for hyatt said quote we
take pride in operating
a highly inclusive environment we
believe that the facilitation of
gatherings is a central element of what
we do as a hospitality company we
believe in the right of individuals and
organizations to peacefully express
their views
independent of the degree to which the
perspectives of those hosting meetings
and events in our hotels align with ours
our own values support a culture that is
characterized by empathy respect and
diversity of opinions and backgrounds we
strive to bring this to light through
what we do
and how we engage with those in our care
and this of course prompted
boycott hyatt to trend on social media
this is how you got trump gang you're
going to keep getting it good and hard
this is how this is how the right is
going to continue pushing into the
culture wars the harder you push
the harder the backlash is going to be
and by the way they are pushing
unbelievably hard
the scariest story of the last couple of
weeks is amazon coming after books
i mean digital book burnings are now a
real thing
according to the daily wire amanda
presta giacomo reporting
conservatives are sounding the alarm
about an updated amazon policy that bans
books the ubiquitous billion dollar
company deems offensive
or includes so-called hate speech as
noted by daily wire amazon has ramped up
its censorship on conservative views in
recent weeks
for example a popular documentary on u.s
supreme court justice clarence thomas
was banned from their streaming service
this past week
before that move the company
deplatformed conservative ryan
anderson's book
critical of gender theory when harry
became sally when just the news reached
out to amazon over at a ban
on anderson's book the outlet directed
them
to a page outlining their content
guidelines for books
under a section labeled defensive
content amazon now states they quote
don't sell certain content
including contact we determine is hate
speech promotes the abuse or sexual
exploitation of children okay so i'm
just going to point out
that you have literally have books
promoting the sexual abuse and
exploitation of children
when you are telling five-year-olds that
they can be members of the opposite sex
and that they might want to get puberty
blockers that is the sexual abuse and
exploitation of children end of story
they say they don't sell certain content
involving content they determine is hate
speech
so if you say that that's bad by the way
that's hate speech contains pornography
glorifies rape or pedophilia advocates
terrorism or other material would deem
inappropriate
or offensive the report says the review
of those policies suggest that sometime
in the last few months
amazon made a major change to the ways
in which it moderates book content on
its servers
imposing a much stricter standard on
books than it had previously done
it appears the company recently added
so-called hate speech to their
guidelines on book platforming and is
amping up their censorship
of the quote unquote offensive this is
going to lead to the complete
cancellation and banning
of conservative books entirely we
already saw them try to do this with
abigail schreier's book
abigail schreier points out when a
company controls over 83 percent of the
market for books
it begins the process of deleting ideas
from a society
a bookseller can sell what it wants if
marxist books wants to only sell books
that conform to its ideology okay that
has integrity but this is the world's
largest bookseller
amazon can basically make books
disappear for all readers
and does so on a blatantly dishonest
basis
my understanding by the way is that even
if you bought these books
they they may have erased them from your
kindle so it doesn't matter if you
already bought the book
like if you have hair when harry became
sally on amazon like he bought it
on the kindle version i believe they've
disappeared it from the kindle somebody
can correct me if i'm wrong
okay this sort of stuff is what
americans are afraid of and they should
be afraid of it because it has infused
all of our society according to ash
scale
boston public schools have suspended
advanced class enrollment tests
right they've decided they're no longer
going to allow you to
enter admission tests and new
enrollments
okay why well because they're afraid
that the people who are doing well on
the test are too white and too asian
and asians of course are not a minority
when they perform well then they're just
white people
according to ash scale new fifth and
sixth graders will not be accepted into
advanced classes in boston the entire
city
for the next year the entry test was
suspended due to the pandemic
while at the same time the school
district has raised concerns about
racial equity problems
noting that a vast majority of students
in those classes are white or asian
gbh news reported the selective program
called advanced work classes will
suspend enrollment because of the
pandemic but also they cited concerns
about equity
because more than 70 percent of students
enrolled in the program were white and
asian even though 80
of boston public school students are
hispanic and black superintendent brenda
casilia said there's been a lot of
inequities they've been brought to light
in the pandemic
there's a lot of work we have to do to
be anti-racist there it is your code
word
anti-racist it's the infusion of this
bull crap throughout all of american
culture
and you will be canceled if you disagree
and your children will be denied
opportunity if you disagree and then
when you flee to a private school they
will follow you there see here's the
thing there
are no places where you get to live your
life the left
has determined that all of society is to
be their safe space
it'd be one thing for them to say okay
we just want our safe space even in this
little domain on campus
then they declared all of campus is our
safe space then they declared all of
corporate america is our safe space
then they declared your church is our
safe space they will soon declare that
your home must also be their safe space
all of society must be their safe space
because in order for them to live
their most fulfilled expressive lives as
we talked about last week
you have to acknowledge and cheer them
it is not enough
for you to just say live your life and
leave me alone that is not enough you
must accept
and cheer them because you see your
failure to cheer is an imposition on
their personal happiness
you are the problem did you know that
every like on this video creates one
additional leftist tier don't ask me why
that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity hit the like button